is that an Asian accent [ __ ] me sir was
your name actually papi and then it's
Bobby in English no what is it
puppy no my real name is how many don't
have any little newborn dogs come when
people call you like a puppy puppy
my name is solo is it really I was
beautiful do you think so yes Armel
someone and my brother's name is
kwang-ho
oh yeah I know that's why his name is
Quan go on on Instagram yeah on
Instagram because that's his Korean name
and I'm so cool you know and someone
means success I think that's what is
Google mean I don't know rash yeah I can
see that yeah yeah yeah by name yeah I
got I gotta go over there somebody said
they were doing a blood drop home you
don't need blood does he somebody sent
bottom maybe I misread some yeah he
doesn't know good good good yeah you
have siblings too though how come we
never met him
they're gonna my brother's gonna come
out here this year for Oakland I'm you
know Disney World
yeah how the children oh they're young
he's 38 he's an adult yeah but is he
like you what does he like no he's kind
of he's like goofy I mean he would think
it was funny you know being like in this
kind of universe that thing but he's
like uh he's kind of goofy but he likes
you know I don't know he's like a smart
guy I know but when he comes yes when he
comes into town
oh yeah will you bring him to the comedy
store oh yeah I'll probably bring him in
the comedy store right will you let me
know that he's so I can show up oh yeah
I'll bring him yeah I love you does he
look like you
yep it looks like me a little bit his
name is f ze F F is f Vaughn Vaughn
Carnot ow ski you guys a good name but
that's your last name yeah I know you're
new less people your last name is Kurt
all scream yeah what is that
I'm polish nicaraguan yeah isn't Vaughn
isn't it Dutch honey who knows you know
somebody [ __ ] on a boat I don't know
how it all happened
be honest with you yeah I'm no land
animal I know that yeah I'm curious
about your dad cuz I know we both have
old dads yeah I met him and I signed at
a meeting seven years old your dad was
right
yep 1910 my dad came here in 1922 he
came to America from Nicaragua
they was mahogany farmers that was over
there doing mahogany I he must have been
a handsome man he's pretty handsome you
know he hit look too low he was you know
he was starting to fall off the bone a
little yeah but to be but to be 70 and
your mom was cute right she was young
yeah my mom was an 8 what was a rule 9 a
rule no yeah la 7 yeah I would say Ya
laysa yeah yeah and she was young right
she was what 20 30 32 when I was born he
was 70 yep 38 year different Wow you
beat me I thought my parents had the
biggest age gap because my parents were
36 years apart wow really yeah oh you're
real bad my real dad yeah not Roger
Roger
Rogers not real yeah [ __ ] handsome
bro you think so I think so don't you
Roger was actually really cute when he
was younger yeah